boa noite já pensarei gênero não prontos
a ir à última e derradeira pois é
conhecido trazer eu aceitei o convite
fui pra falar pra vocês tá pra encerrar
esse dia maravilhoso a gente está
refletindo sobre o futuro da nossa amada
família deixa eu falei amada
isso vai acontecer durante a palestra eu
vou tentar continuar nos 6 amar mais os
nossos adversários então o futuro não
está escrito nas estrelas segundo
tivesse um simples nas estrelas ambiente
teriam montado em um só lugar para falar
que era mas eu sou a soma fez astronomia
na universidade federal do rio de
janeiro
eu quero supersimples é uma mensagem de
otimismo é uma mensagem transformadora
eu acredito que tudo o que a gente acha
que é produto dos nossos sócios é
produto da nossa luta mas é um produto
também a coragem da jesus tema super
para mudar
eu acredito que a ufrj seja ação preso
momentos de coragem
a não passar por esse momento de coragem
para mudar ela não vai se transformar na
universidade dos nossos sonhos na
universidade que a gente quer deixar
para a próxima geração
bom eu sou filho da ufrj já falei para
vocês que eu estudei aqui assim como eu
sou filha e vejam a milhares de outras
pessoas a boca e jogue desde a sua
fundação
nós entramos na ufrj logo após a
adolescência muitos ainda são
adolescentes of a gente se transforma
dentro da ufrj
a gente sai da adolescência a gente
virar adulto a gente viu até
profissional do wsj são aqueles 45 anos
há seis vezes até sete anos de dedicação
aqui o fmi só vamos transformar duras na
vida da gente então a ufrj tem prestado
é um transformador nas nossas mãos da
ufrj vai ser transformada com vocês pela
geração está aqui hoje pelos estudantes
da ufrj de hoje de a moda trouxe danos e
então vocês lá e sempre eu mostro a
minha vida na história a botar tudo
dentro de um contexto para vocês também
porque teste pede pra gente fazer isso
então vou mostrar pra vocês uma foto de
uma professora com vários estudantes
nossa 70 no colégio não muito longe
daqui bonsucesso foi o colégio e
oriental anexada
a dirigente também a bola eu olhe é
muito fácil achado ilha como também
professor na foto da comida sempre do
lado do professor
eu sempre fui muito apegado aos meus
professores eu adorava professor eu
ainda adoro o professor eu sou
professora há quem estudou lado da dona
lucia a professora quem não me viu ainda
eu sou aquela menina lhe de franjinha do
lado da dona lucia essa aqui porque
gosto de professor porque eu sou apegado
o professor porque eu tô falando isso
pra vocês falando isso porque eu acho
que esse é um dos pilares da
transformação da ufrj
a gente precisa se apegar mais aos
professores de professores precisam
saber ganhar mais alunos
gostaria de lembrar que os professores
eles estão ensinando a uma geração que é
diferente da geração deles ea gente
precisa os professores precisam se
modernizar e falar a linguagem do
estudante
a gente tem que lembrar que a maioria de
vocês a criança chamada geração milénio
geração do google é a direção da equipe
já do desapego à geração pede essa
geração é a geração para resposta
imediata à pergunta que ainda nem tem na
cabeça o estudante mandar e mail pra
gente e mail não é que hoje em dia em
meio a coisa de velho né
ele acaba falando com o professor com o
método antigo que é e mail
ele manda uma pergunta às duas horas da
manhã de um domingo quebrando a resposta
porque ele está conectado 100% do tempo
24 horas do dia e o professor não está o
professor não está usando o método do
estudante de comunicação
então esses métodos de comunicações são
muito importante pra modernizar a ufrj
eu acho que esse é um dos pilares da
mudança da ufrj uma comunicação mais
moderna entre professor e aluno
eu trouxe essa essa foto aí pra vocês
muitos de vocês já devem ter visto esse
filme quem não viu veja é uma foto do
filme sociedade dos poetas mortos um
grande filme comparecido robbie williams
e que lhe dá um show
nesse filme de interpretação de um
professor
esse professor que o barril ilhas
interpreta ele é um professor capitão
ele é um professor líbia
ele é um professor reservar esses
professores existem aqui na ufrj eles
foram meus professores também e muitos
já têm uma geração nova desses
professores eu gostaria de pedir vocês
os estudantes da ufrj que identificassem
os professores que foi assim que admirar
sem esses professores que fossem nas
salas desses professores e conversassem
com eles ou procurar sem saber como é a
vida desses professores
eu gostaria de pedir a vocês que não sei
se apegar sem esses professores
isso é importante porque isso faz a todo
mundo crescer junto com o professor
capitão a um professor mentor
eu sou mentora e aliás tem alguns dos
meus é
pupilo sakina na platéia eu sou leitora
de muitos alunos que não foram meus
alunos mas que me procuram na internet
vocês não me procuraram podem me
procurar eu faço um programa de mentoria
cantando mostrar pra vocês o que é por
exemplo ser cientista procura em
conversa com seus professores
procurem saber porque ele é professor da
ufrj e porque isso é importante porque a
ufrj é uma empresa ouro de pessoas
e vocês precisam descobrir esse tesouro
mas é um tipo é street não é só o
professor aluno é também o aluno
professor então professor tem aberto
para o aluno e o aluno tempo aberto
professor bom e aí eu peço a vocês que
vistam a camisa da ufrj
isso é super importante tem um orgulho
da ufrj
um dos primeiros professores da palestra
hoje que pagou mico que chorou né
eu disse que eu ia chorar ele a alô pra
gente que a ufrj é um presente no lixão
ufrj é um presente eu considero a ufrj
um presente na minha vida e é por isso
que eu tô com quem tenho muito orgulho
de estar aqui hoje falando com vocês
vista uma camisa da ufrj
tenho orgulho da ufrj e quando vocês
terminarem na ufrj e tornem a ufrj
quando você já forem pessoas de sucesso
retornem à ufrj venham aqui ajudem a
ufrj sempre crescer
lembrem-se que isso aí em qual
crescimento da ufrj é importante para
cada um de vocês falou de quando vocês
tenham ufrj nos seus currículos
então o crescimento da ufrj
serem também sejam orgulhosos da ufrj
voltem aqui sempre que puder continua
investindo a camisa da ufrj
ou eu falei pra vocês né que é a geração
de hoje que os professores de hoje estão
lhe dando uma geração diferente da minha
geração com seu fosse professora da ufrj
itália estaria dando aula para a geração
de vocês mas como que era quando eu era
da idade de vocês com eu era menina nerd
na época a gente chamava de cdf né mas
eu era menina nerd eu adorava ficção
científica
então ali estão as ficções científicas
da ocasião na época né
colado em star trek está roxo nas
estrelas né perdido o espaço tem o
cosmos com o qual seja que não é ficção
mas que é o grande show na tv e eu
coloquei aqui um trechinho de um aderno
velho que eu tinha que mostrava 3 das
minhas paixões dessa época o direito aos
15 anos eu escrevi isso em todos os meus
cadernos na contra-capa dos meus
cadernos eram três das minhas paixões
não se está dando pra ver aí todo mundo
ver claramente o que está escrito
ele escrevia flamengo o melhor time do
mundo porque eu cresci nessa isso aí
gente lembra que foi alfabetizada em
1970 eu tinha 6 anos 1970 então nessa
época estou falando dos anos até dos
anos 70 foi a pique flamengo foi três
vezes prefeito tricampeão época do tri
então há o flamengo era muito importante
na minha vida
outra coisa que é muito importante na
minha vida é o maior roqueiro de todos
os tempos e tanto
se vocês nunca ouviram falar de peter
cantu por favor quando chegar em casa o
dever de casa do google peter frampton
youtube
peter cantu vocês vão se apaixonar como
eu quando tinha 15 anos e eu tinha uma
outra paixão a minha outra paixão era
uma nave espacial
uma sonda espacial que a nasa tinha
mandado pelo sistema solar que se
chamava paione 11 já ouviu falar de
menina que tinha nave espacial favorita
não tinha era só eu
então essa paixão que eu tinha por cento
espacial por astronomia é uma coisa que
vinha desde quando eu era adolescente
então o que eu fiz eu falei pra minha
mãe que queria fazer a astronomia
aqui são as descobertas da apae unirc
que motivaram a tomar essa atitude que
eu ia fazer astronomia queria um dia
participar de descobertas como essa
bom eu falei pra minha mãe que eu queria
fazer astronomia
a minha mãe falou astro que eu sou de
uma família à classe média simples a
gente morava no subúrbio carioca é nem
meu pai e minha mãe fizeram faculdade e
nós éramos assim a o dinheiro era curto
meus três irmãos jatinhos entrada para a
universidade com muito sacrifício e eu
era a última a entrar para a
universidade ea minha mãe era muito
preocupada com o meu futuro porque ela a
achava que eu ia morrer de fome fazendo
isso que ela não sabia que significa
então ela teve uma brilhante idéia
ela me lembrou no observatório do
valongo da ufrj
bom nós na ocasião morávamos no subúrbio
carioca e brás de pina já ouviram falar
morava e brás defina sair lá dá para a
esquina da rua bahia eu e minha mãe
seis anos eu e minha mãe fomos lá no
centro da cidade ela não veio aqui na
cidade universitária porque ela só ficou
sabendo assim como thiago gol né
mas ela ficou sabendo que a astronomia
era lá no centro da cidade no
observatório do calor
então nós pegamos o uso online para a
indisciplina
daí uma hora e 45 minutos
a gente chegou no centro da cidade o
centro velho do rio de janeiro se vocês
nunca foram ao observatório do valongo
eu recomendo é um lugar super bucólica
um lugar lindo que fica no meio da
favela no centro do rio de janeiro no
morro da providência no bairro da saúde
bom aí gente estava calor a gente subiu
aquela ladeira é famosa ladeira do
valongo ladeira do pedro antônio e assim
mais ou menos no meio da ladeira minha
mãe começou a se arrepender daquela
idéia maravilhosa que ela permite levar
no morro do valongo mas ainda não
chegamos lá em cima quando a gente
chegou lá em cima
tinha alguns estudantes que tinham
alguns professores
nós conversamos com alguns deles e os
estudantes nos levaram para conhecer o
relógio atômico relógio atômico foice
transformador na minha vida quando viu
hoje atômica e eu fiquei eu tinha 16
anos e eu fiquei de boca aberta porque
parecia filme de ficção científica hoje
disse vocês vivenciam redirigir porque é
só uma caixa e sim fomos uns pininho não
tem nada mais que isso
mas aquilo pra mim era absolutamente
fantástico era hora mais precisa do
brasil tinha césio atento alimento
elemento químico radioativo já penso eu
achava isso máximo bom aí a minha mãe
aí nós vamos ver vamos embora né na
descida da ladeira minha mãe
para o pé no chão e eu lá nas nuvens
virou pra mim e falou assim a filha de
cinema você quer fazer e falei ela foi
maravilhoso
ela falou você é maluca aí eu falei 'não
sou maluca manhã que eu adorei a ela foi
mas aonde você vai arrumar emprego
depois aí a resposta que eu dei pra
minha mãe é uma resposta reveladora
eu falei pra minha mãe seguinte o é de
professores da ufrj não são astronômicos
nos seus empregados
por que eu não posso ser uma professora
da ufrj
aí caiu a ficha aí a minha mãe deixou eu
fazer vestibular da astronomia e eu fiz
aqui nessa foto é uma foto de 1981
tirada aquino cml onde nós éramos todos
os cabeludos é tem vários têm algumas
pessoas aqui duas pessoas aqui estão
presentes é no auditório aqui no cmi
aquino na física que no bloco há também
algumas pessoas aqui que não estão
presentes mas que onde tem ainda ligado
à ufrj
eu o curso de física porque quem faz
gastronomia faz tem que fazer física e
fazer física fazer matemática de todas
as matérias aqui no fundão depois casa
trouxe ela no valongo né
bom então aquilo que eu falei pra vocês
de que eu falei pra minha mãe que o
professor é o cientista é uma coisa
super importante que eu acho que nós
somos culpados professores são culpados
de não revelar isso mais para a
sociedade precisa falar mas isso vocês
por favor falem isso pra todos porque
existe hoje um
o conceito conta o professor quando a
gente fala que a você é ser cientista
você depois foi trabalhar na
universidade você professor ia como se
tivesse jogado um banho de água fria
naquela criança naquele jovem professor
de jeito nenhum não quero isso de jeito
nenhum eu quero ser cientista mas eu não
quero ser professor
o professor é um cientista e o cientista
um professor isso é uma coisa que a
gente precisa esclarecer mais a
sociedade professor é um especialista
professor é o intelectual o professor é
um pensador professor é a alma da
sociedade uma sociedade que se esquece
disso é uma sociedade que não merece
crescer
gostaria que vocês pensar só nisso eu
gostaria de pedir a todos vocês aqui que
ajudar nessa campanha de valorização do
professor
aí eu viajei na maionese o tempo
passando rápido a um índice mas eu sou a
última então não tô nem aí se tem
passado muito a minha universidade do
futuro essa daí ó ufrj do futuro é uma
necessidade conectada com a mídia a
universidade conectada com a indústria
universidade internacionalizada da
universidade preocupada com o meio
ambiente
meio ambiente é muito importante a gente
mora dentro do complexo da maré
a gente precisa lembrar disso a gente
precisa mudar e você gosta de lembrar da
universidade sem o cheiro de marize com
cheiro de mais difíceis cheiro de esgoto
como a gente pode formar futuros
biólogos aqui ao lado dessa bahia foi
fedorenta com o que a gente pode formar
futuros engenheiros em prédios que estão
caindo como que a gente pode ter um
hospital ao lado de um prédio abandonado
a gente precisa ir apelo à ufrj sem
apego não vai roubar não vai transformar
a gente precisa ter apego aos vizinhos
isso aí é uma foto tirada na redes da
maré
a gente precisa ir lá a gente precisa
ter coragem de ir lá lá na maré mesmo se
transformar necessário coragem
necessário se arriscavam mos todos lá na
maré
vamos todos trazer as crianças a maré
para a ufrj e nós temos que lá só assim
a gente vai escrever o nome da ufrj nas
estrelas muito obrigada
[Aplausos]